Imagina que pudieras cobrar un sueldo de 600
dólares al mes por no hacer absolutamente
nada. Has oído bien. Un sueldo que cobrarías
por el mero hecho de existir. Todos los meses,
tacatá, el Gobierno te paga 600 dólares.
A ti y a todos los ciudadanos de tu país.
¡No me he vuelto loco! Esto se llama la RENTA
BÁSICA UNIVERSAL y es una política defendida,
en mayor o menor medida, por muchos economistas
como, por ejemplo, Milton Friedman.
Ya me puedo imaginar lo que os estaréis preguntando
muchos: ¿De dónde se saca el dinero para
pagar todo eso? ¿Qué sentido tiene? ¿A
quién se le ha ocurrido semejante locura?
Pues… lo cierto es que FINLANDIA ya ha empezado
a experimentar con esto de la Renta Básica
Universal. Es sólo un experimento peor ya
han corrido ríos de tinta. Y casi todos…
bastante críticos. Hoy, vamos a explicar
por qué.
Finlandia es un país mundialmente conocido
por una cosa: es la patria del METAL.
Hablamos del país con la mayor densidad de
bandas de heavy metal per cápita. Para que
os hagáis una idea, hay más de 600 bandas
de metal por cada millón de habitantes. En
otras palabras, que si vais a las fiestas
de un pueblo de Finlandia, no os van a tocar
ni Paquito el Chocolatero ni Reggaton. En
estas latitudes, incluso las abuelas agitan
sus melenas al ritmo de bandas como STRATOVARIUS,
SONATA ARCTICA o NIGHWISH.
Pero vamos a dejar los cuernos y los solos
de guitarra a un lado. Lo cierto es que, durante
años, Finlandia era algo así como el hermano
pobre de los países nórdicos. Un país con
pocas oportunidades y muchísimos problemas
de alcoholismo. Sin embargo, todo eso es historia.
Hoy en día, Finlandia es uno de los países
más ricos de la Eurozona y están a la vanguardia
en lo que se refiere a Educación. Hablamos
de la patria que vio nacer a los móviles
de NOKIA o a videojuegos como el ANGRY BIRDS.
Sin embargo… las cosas últimamente no van
demasiado bien en este país. A ver, no podemos
decir que estén en crisis ni muchísimo menos.
Pero está claro que este país no pasa por
su mejor momento económico. NOKIA, que es
la empresa icónica de Finlandia está en
horas bajas. Su principal exportación, que
es el papel, está bajando dramáticamente.
Y uno de sus mayores socios comerciales, que
es Rusia, tampoco está en condiciones de
comprar nada.
¿Y qué hacen los Finlandeses cuando su economía
va mal? Pues… no se les ocurre nada mejor
que hacer un experimento. Tal vez uno de los
experimentos políticos más ambiciosos de
la historia.
Finlandia considera introducir la renta básica
universal en 2017
¡Ya sé lo que estaréis pensando! Seguro
que Finlandia tiene un gobierno de extrema
izquierda ¿VerdaD? Pues nada más lejos de
la realidad. El Primer Ministro de Finlandia
es este señor que veis aquí, que se llama
JUHA SIPILA y que anteriormente era uno de
los empresarios más ricos del país. Para
que os hagáis una idea, el Gobierno de Finlandia,
es una coalición que va desde el centro hasta
la derecha populista. Es más, este experimento
está encuadrado dentro de un paquete de medidas
para acabar con el gasto público. Es decir,
que el Gobierno finés quiere poner una renta
básica universal para… ¡RECORTAR PRESUPUESTO!
Y como decíamos al principio, todo esto no
es más que un EXPERIMENTO. Es decir, no es
que Finlandia haya dicho “a partir de ahora,
le vamos a dar a todo el mundo 560 euros al
mes”. No. Lo que han hecho ha sido juntar
a 2000 personas y probar durante dos años.
¿Puede llegar a funcionar algo así? ¿De
verdad se puede recortar gasto con una renta
básica universal? ¿Cuál es el propósito
real de este experimento? Hoy vamos a responder
a esta pregunta pero antes, vamos a ver un
poco de historia.
MONEY FOR NOTHING
Hay dos grandes escuelas a la hora de defender
la renta básica universal. Por un lado tenemos
a los que defienden que todos los ciudadanos
de un país cobren un sueldo MUY generoso.
Algo que se acercara al salario medio. Por
ejemplo, hace unos años, Suiza celebró un
referendum donde se proponía una renta de
unos 2500 dólares por ciudadano. Ese dinero
es suficiente para que mucha gente pudiera
plantearse dejar de trabajar. Y el resultado
de esa votación fue un rotundo: NO ¿Por
qué? Pues básicamente, por ese dinero no
cae del cielo. Para que os hagáis una idea,
según un estudio de la Fundación BBVA, aplicar
una renta básica universal de este tipo en
España nos obligaría a pagar hasta un 40%
más de impuestos. Eso por no hablar de lo
que ocurre si la gente no trabaja. En otras
palabras, que es bastante difícil defender
una política así.
Ahora bien, hay otra forma de entender la
renta básica universal. Según muchos economistas,
podría ser un sustituto de las ayudas sociales.
Por ejemplo, este señor que vais a ver ahora
se llama MILTON FRIEDMAN y, aparte de tener
un premio nobel de economía, es uno de los
grandes abanderados del libre mercado. Sin
embargo, esto es lo que dice sobre una renta
básica.
“El impuesto negativo sobre la renta es
una propuesta para ayudar a los pobres dándoles
dinero, que es lo que necesitan, en lugar
de lo que tenemos ahora, que requiere que
los la gente se presente ante un funcionario,
le diga lo que tiene, sus activos, sus pasivos…
y que luego le digan que se tienen que gastar
X dólares en alquiler, Y dólares en comida…”
Veréis, a día de hoy, prácticamente todos
los países conceden ayudas a los más desfavorecidos.
Desde prestaciones por desempleo hasta cheques
de comida. Por ejemplo, las familias más
pobres de República Dominicana reciben un
cheque de 18 dólares todos los meses para
alimentos. En principio parece una buena idea
¿Dónde está el problema? Pues que cada
familia tiene necesidades distintas. Y lo
mismo ocurre con otras ayudas. Por ejemplo,
hay muchas ayudas condicionadas a no tener
trabajo. Es decir, que en el momento en el
que consigas un empleo, dejas de recibirlas.
Según muchos economistas, esto desincentiva
a mucha gente a buscar trabajo ¿Hasta qué
punto tienen razón? Eso daría para otro
vídeo. Pero lo cierto es que la Renta Básica
Universal, al menos, como sustituto de las
ayudas sociales, tiene defensores incluso
en el mundo de la empresa.
Elon Musk dice que la Renta Básica Universal
va a ser necesaria
Y os preguntaréis ¿Funciona? ¿Es una buena
idea? Lo cierto es que no lo sabemos… ¡Porque
nunca se ha probado! Hasta la fecha, se están
haciendo experimentos en ciudades como Ontario,
en Canadá o Barcelona, en España. Pero nadie
ha llegado tan lejos como Finlandia ¿Qué
han hecho exactamente en este país? Ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver.
EL EXPERIMENTO FINLANDÉS
En el año 2016, el llamado KELA, que es la
Seguridad Social Finlandesa comenzó este
experimento. Escogieron, de forma aleatoria,
a 2000 personas que estaban cobrando ayudas
de parte del estado: parados, minusválidos
o gente con algún tipo de baja laboral. Durante
los siguientes 2 años, estos 2000 afortunados
estuvieron cobrando 560 € al mes. Y diréis
¿Cuánto le ha costado esto al gobierno?
Pues la respuesta es NADA. Por ejemplo, imagina
que vives en Helsinki, en Finlandia, y cobras
una baja por discapacidad. Una cantidad muy
normal en este país serían 860 euros al
mes. Pues bien, en este caso, si estás cobrando
esta renta básica universal, la baja por
discapacidad se te reduce a 300 euros y los
otros 560 euros restantes vendrían por el
experimento.
¿Y os preguntaréis… cuál es la diferencia?
¿Qué más da cobrar de una forma o de otra?
Pues veréis, si cobras la baja por discapacidad,
el Estado dejará de pagarte en el momento
en el cual encuentres un trabajo. Sin embargo,
la Renta Básica Universal la puedes cobrar
hagas lo que hagas.
Y ahora os preguntaréis. Pero… ¿Por qué
los medios de comunicación dicen que este
proyecto ha fracasado? Pues lo cierto es que
a principios de este año 2018, los directores
de esta iniciativa pidieron al Gobierno que
ampliaran el programa. Es decir, que en lugar
de dar 560 euros a gente que está cobrando
ayudas del Estado, se los dieran también
a otras 1000 o 2000 personas que NO están
cobrando ningún tipo de ayuda. Y ahí es
donde el parlamento votó en contra.
Y
aquí viene la pregunta del millón ¿A que
no adivináis quién está en contra de la
Renta Básica Universal? ¡Exacto!
Según el sindicato más grande de Finlandia,
la Renta Básica Universal no sirve para nada
En resumen, que hasta principios del año
2019, no tendremos ningún dato sobre este
experimento. Pero ¿Por qué hay tantas críticas?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
UN ESTUDIO SESGADO
La primera pregunta que os estaréis haciendo
es… ¿De verdad es suficiente con 560 euros
para vivir en Finlandia? Y la respuesta es
no. El salario medio en este país es de 3500
euros. Es decir, que esos 560 euros en Finlandia
serían el equivalente a unos 300 euros en
España. Para que os hagáis una idea, sólo
el alquiler de un piso pequeño en Helsinki
cuesta más de 800 euros. Una simple colonoscopia
en un hospital normal puede costar unos 700
euros. Es decir, que, en el mejor de los casos,
esta renta básica universal sería una simple
ayuda. En ningún caso sería un sustituto
de los servicios públicos ni, muchísimo
menos de un salario.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Pero cuánto podría
costar? Es decir… suponiendo que dejara
de ser un experimento y, a partir de 2019,
todos los finlandeses cobraran una renta básica
universal ¿De cuánto dinero estaríamos
hablando? Pues hablamos de más de 3000 millones
de euros. Y en un país tan pequeño como
Finlandia, eso sí que es una cantidad considerable.
Por supuesto, si ampliáramos la ayuda, podríamos
hablar de problemas mucho mayores.
¡Pero este no es el único problema! Veréis,
parte del interés de este estudio es ver
lo que ocurre si damos dinero a cambio de
nada. Es decir, si tú cobras 560 euros, estés
o no estés en el paro… ¿Seguirás buscando
trabajo o no? Y lo cierto es que el estudio
también está viciado en este sentido. Porque
todos los participantes saben que es una ayuda
que sólo dura 2 años. Es decir, que es muy
probable que los resultados de este estudio
estén sesgados. Y por eso, las críticas
a este experimento están llegando por todos
los flancos.
La OECD pide a Finlandia que abandone la renta
básica y rediseñe los programas de ayudas
sociales
Pero ahora vamos a cambiar de tema. Antes
de terminar el vídeo de hoy vamos a empezar
una nueva sección en VisualPolitik. Últimamente,
recibimos un montón de preguntas muy interesantes
a través de nuestro PATREON. Preguntas que
seguro que más de uno se ha hecho alguna
vez. Así que hemos pensado que, mejor que
responder por mensaje privado, vamos a responder
por aquí. Hoy tenemos a Óscar Zeballos-Zúñiga
que nos pregunta por la bonanza económica
de Portugal con un gobierno de izquierdas.
A ver, Óscar. lo primero que hay que dejar
claro es que los gobiernos de izquierdas pueden
ser tan buenos o tan malos en la economía
como los de derechas. Aquí en VisualPolitik
hemos contado cómo el gobierno laborista
de Nueva Zelanda, en los 80, sacó al país
de la crisis. En el caso de Portugal, han
hecho recortes en infraestructura y luego
han dado muchas facilidades fiscales en sectores
estratégicos. Por ejemplo, si eres autónomo
y te estableces en territorio portugués,
tienes unas vacaciones fiscales de varios
años. Eso ha ayudado a que muchas pequeñas
empresas se instalen en el país. A eso hay
que sumarle que, en general, toda Europa está
creciendo. Portugal también. Si crecen más,
pueden recaudar más impuestos. Y eso explica
por que están saliendo de la crisis. En cualquier
caso, llevamos meses trabajando en un vídeo
sobre Portugal donde trataremos todo esto
más a fondo.
Gracias por tu pregunta, Óscar, y a todos
los demás, si queréis consultarnos cualquier
duda, os vemos en Patreon.
Mientras tanto, ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros ¿Creéis que este experimento de
Finlandie servirá para sacar conclusiones
útiles? Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta
pronto.